الوضع لديك كيف هو على المستويين الميداني
وايضا الانسان
اسماعيل نعم في البدايه نتحدث عن الوضع
الميداني هو استمرار الاشتباكات والقصف
العنيف من قوات الاحتلال في المناطق
الغربيه الجنوبيه بالتحديد تتواجد دبابات
واليات الاحتلال في منطقه الصناعه ومنطقه
جنوب حي الرمال ومنطقه التجمع الجامعات
بالاضافه لمنطقه ت تل الهواء ومنطقه اطراف
حي الصبره او المناطق المطله على حي
الصبرا كل هذه المناطق الان تتواجد اليات
الاحتلال بشكل كثيف جدا وتتعرض لقصف مدفعي
متواصل منذ ساعات ليله امس حتى هذه اللحظه
بالاضافه الى سماع دوء اصوات الانفجارات
والاشتباكات ما بين فينا واخرى حتى هذه
اللحظه تسمع تسمع اصوات الانفجارات في هذه
المناطق بشكل ملحوظ جدا مع استمرار تواجد
قوات الاحتلال هذه المنطقه يبدو انها
تتعرض لاشتباكات عنيفه ما بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه او فصائل المقاومه و وما بين
قوات الاحتلال حتى هذه اللحظه الانفجارات
متتاليه اما اذا ما تحدثنا عن الوضع
الانساني في شمال قطع غزه نتحدث عن وضع
انساني خطير جدا ونحن في في شمال قطاع غزه
ال العائلات على حافه مجاعه حقيقيه في ظل
عدم دخول مساعدات الانسانيه لايام طويله
نحن نتحدث عن قرابه سته ايام الان متواصله
لا تدخل اي مساعدات في حين انها دخلت قبل
ايام شاحنات محدوده جدا تقل عن عدد 10
شاحنات ونحن نتحدث عن احتياج كبير في شمال
قطاع غزه للشاحنات الانسانيه والغذائيه عن
الدقيق نتحدث عن المعلبات عن باقي الامور
الاساسيه التي تحتاج الى تغذيه في ظل ايضا
تحذير الانرو قبل ايام من نقص ال التغذيه
وا التخوف من مجاعه حقيقيه نحن نتحدث الان
عن كارثه انسانيه كبيره جدا ايضا في ظل
البرد الشديد التي يتعرض له اهالي شمال
قطاع غزه في ظل ايضا تدمير مراكز الايواء
التي دمرت بفعل قوات الاحتلال في مختلف
المناطق لا اغطيه الان ولا ملابس كاف وحتى
لا مراكز ايواء تقي المواطنين من هذا
البرد شكرا لك اسماعيل الغول